for the wii u category I think any of
the nominees could have been the game of
the year for Wii U and and everybody
would have been happy but but in the end
mario kart 8 is the one that tried over
it and just like in the game itself
Brandi you were leading the charge on
that and you almost always be be in
Mario Kart you're right this was one of
the toughest I think in terms of the
quality of the games because we're all
pretty much up there this year I mean
obviously you know we're talking a bit
about banner the two later but right now
i think mario kart 8 is I think
unanimously everyone in our room decided
that that was the best that Mario Kart
could possible be you know there was
some disappointment you know expressed
about Mario Kart 7 but eight seem to
just bring it all back you know bring
back everything that people loved about
the track design they know the the charm
the characters and the fact that is
coming out with DLC which is a pretty
cool thing for Nintendo to do and that
VLC is it is pretty awesome DLC right
and I think the one thing that everyone
kept coming back to when they talked
about Mario Kart is how often they
actually come back to this game right so
like everyone else is you know busy
they're playing all sorts of other gangs
but mario kart 8 seemed to be that game
where you have had friends over at
downtime they would put that on have a
bit of fun and you know having poles
have an awesome time I feel like it's
one of those games like you said like
the dlc it's gonna give it longevity and
I think it's a wonderful thing that
Nintendo is establishing now with the
wii u like they can create these games
that have a wonderful base and build on
top of them and things people are happy
to come back to them even with just the
base set of tracks and characters and
karts but man like when you get new
stuff like it just keeps reinvigorating
your interest like when we played some
of the stuff with link you know from
zelda like this is a nintendo universe
right and like so many people love that
because it's such a well established and
well-defined place and mario kart is
just one of those those avenues where
nintendo can kind of express what they
do best kind of like smash brothers but
this is obviously a different genre they
did it really well it's a fantastic
racing I don't think the elephant in the
room obviously is bad man yes our
Bayonetta 2 babies ready ok beta 2 is
the elf
room obviously because that got a 10
from us the very first ten against what
for I want to say 40 years I mean
obviously lot of people have questions
as to why that didn't automatically get
up there and I think you know there was
a little debate about that but you know
like what did you feel marathon it
should have gotten ahead of playing
bayonetta 2 I think you've despite all
the obvious tonal problems with a game
it's a perfect action game but mario
kart 8 just it's like the game that
keeps on giving like people are gonna be
playing mario kart 8 this time next year
until you know the wii u goes out of
style and the way you two comes out and
the next mario kart comes out i feel
like this game will just continue to be
like it's a staple and everyone can play
it what's not limited in the audience
and I think that's why it sort of
deserves that recognition yeah and I
think just back trainees point about you
know pain I've got a 10 that was our
reviewers decision to you know scored
that game that way and we thought he
argued it pretty well but you know took
a lot of the room we all have our own
opinions on these things it's not just
like a high of mind where we come to one
decision so for anyone wondering I guess
maybe why we didn't just default to the
game that got to 10 that's why you know
we all have played some of these games
and we all see them in different ways a
team vote right it's what gamespot feel
should be you know like the lead vote
for this platform you know when it came
down to it when we went around and ask
people you know what is the game that
you would recommend to someone but you
should buy if you got a wii u this year
most people went down to Mario aidan
mario kart 8 and and and that's why
mario kart 8 i think is our deserving
winner for the wii u category this year
you